[Applause]
spotlight is strong with this one
all right thanks
yeah i'm david and today i'm the talk is
hitchhiker guide to mlaps
it's a bit of a hooky title but
i thought it was a good idea since we
are in london and it's one of my
favorite books
um
and why do i have this title it's not
just the hook
dda is mlaps for those who don't know
machine learning operations
is becoming more and more hot there is a
lot of talks around
companies products
open source non-open source
just a lot of it and if you open your
browser and google it it can be kind of
scary like if you're looking into the
universe and there is just way too much
so sometimes you just want like a couple
of easy answers to get going and
maybe get some ideas especially if this
is the first time you're starting with
this topic which was me
some time ago and hope that this will
help some of you that are getting
started in wanting to know more about
them lapse
so if you don't have a towel grab your
notebook which i did these slides are
made with a jupiter notebook i love it
so unsolicited i'm gonna say a little
bit about me
machine learning operations engineer at
massive entertainment we're one of the
ubisoft studios
really proud
developers of some
aaa games like the division world and
conflicts i don't know if anybody plays
these
and now also working on
games in the world of avatar from james
cameron and star wars big fan
when i'm not at work doing machine
learning i'm also a guitarist in a metal
band that i'm 100 sure none of you has
ever heard of
fortunately
that's not what should have happened
oh
um
so
emelops
i still get a question
a lot which is do i need to care about
it and i get it from people within the
field
and usually i
i
it's becoming a thing
people are starting to understand more
about it but usually i get it towards
the end of a project when people have
released their hard work machine
learning model in production and they're
like oh well there is actually more to
this
because i actually think one of the
underrated part of this whole process
and we'll see it in a bit what all
things that go around it are
is about um what actually happens after
you have released a product this kind of
little forgotten piece
and what i do is like i start talking
about this kind of funny example
which is maybe some of you remember 2016
when microsoft released a chat bot
called tay i thought it was pretty fun
at that time um
so what happened the idea was the the
chatbot was
had the possibility to interact with
people
and learn what it means to you know
discuss with humans chat tweet and so on
uh the idea is super awesome the problem
is that within 24 hours something really
wholesome and cute transformed into a
genocidal racist
because human beings are tricky
so what happened
then i thought about it and it's like
okay if i could go back
in time and i was the one releasing this
chat bot probably you wanted to set
something like a kpi for
when you had your model out there and
was starting to train on new data so the
new tweets and maybe this kpi was
something like about racism
and then perhaps you could set a
threshold and be like okay you know if
the if the value of this kind of racism
metric that i'm tracking goes beyond a
certain threshold probably want to start
taking a look
and stop my model
updating probably something has changed
maybe the data is not what i expected or
that kind of stuff
um
and this kind of centers to uh
almost like philosophical question but
the main question which is also the
topic of this talk is
do i need to monitor my machine learning
system which is one of the parts of
mlaps and i think the question is
in a world that is becoming more and
more data driven
sorry for the buzzword data informed
systems are making decisions
autonomously and
and just you know we want that we want
machine learning to support our all our
processes but do we want to let the
models run by themselves in an
unexpected world full of you know all
the unpredicted events which are data in
our case or do we want to keep an eye on
the models and track what they're doing
over time in case we need to go
all blade runner on them
like sometimes you have to do
um
here i wanted to stop a bit before we
get into the whole part of the talk and
that's kind of uh a question which is
not what you're seeing here this was as
to dali
the question is whoever is who has
released
a machine learning application model
system to let's say production
all right
who has released
such a system without monitoring on it
yeah
yeah i don't know i was young and i
wanted to live on the edge but i think
it's time to move on
but i'm happy that i'm not alone yeah we
are all in the same place
all right so what are we gonna talk at
the beginning i'll just give you like a
really short introduction of what devops
and mlaps here for those who never heard
about it really a no panic introduction
to start seeing what are the
similarities and what what goes in there
but then i'll focus on what i mentioned
monitoring there is like the big part of
this and also like like the low-hanging
fruit like a really accessible part of
this whole complicated stack and i'm
going to do it in a practical way we'll
we'll show two tools that you can use
being
one ml flow that is a platform that can
be used for tracking
your systems and one for monitoring on
top of it called grafana
and then i'll just conclude with some
tips some resources if anybody wants to
look into this more and hopefully
questions if i manage to not go over
time
so devops it has a similar name than
mlaps so there must be some similarities
in here
this has been around for a long time
in traditional software development it's
all the
tools and processes and all the best
practices that help developers getting
more collaborative
fast reliable
been able to monitor release test
automate all the things that go around
making software
it's pretty good of course things are
changing because you know the world
changes uh in terms of tech
infrastructure and so not but the ideas
stays the same and the objectives are
those
but if we could just take it since it's
been around for so long
that'd be awesome talk would be over
mlabs
solved but
things are not that easy
this is like a super simplified
diagram of the differences between
traditional software and machine
learning while in traditional software
we could say that most of the
challenges and the outcome of the
release say the outcome of
of your development depends on the code
itself
itself
in machine learning we have two
additional components of course we have
code we have to write some pattern
uh but we also have data
data that comes in the system will
affect how the code performs and also we
have things like parameters so if we
change parameters of a system from one
run to the other things can both either
run or not or they can run in different
ways that can be really hard to predict
so there are additional challenges that
are not present in
traditional software
so what is amelops
here i wanted to quote a definition that
was given i think last year in a google
paper
where they start taking a look at what
mlap says i think it's nice that finally
they're starting to get some
standardization in the definitions and
mlaps provides a set of standardized
processes and technology capabilities
for building deploying and
operationalizing
machine learning systems rapidly and
reliably so the definition is very
similar to what devops is
but of course now we are dealing with
these additional challenges
so this is a bit of a um
again kind of a diagram of coming from
the same paper or what the different
phases are and i'm going to go through
most of them really quickly
because i want to focus on the
monitoring part that you see here on the
top left
but if we start from the top we have
machine learning development we know
that we've all done it in our notebook
and whatnot then there are
components that deal with being able to
now wrap our code that perhaps is not
ready to just run on production uh
wrap it in such a way that it can be
trained on demand and can be scheduled
for example the continuous training or
can be triggered on data events and
whatnot
then there is the part about actually
being able to take now this model that
we have trained and it's able to train
online over time and actually deployed
and been able to be queried and
predictions to be served
and then there is last but not least the
continuous monitoring part
um and it's important because in my
opinion this is like again really the
unappreciated step because i've been
myself in that situation before where i
have let's say five months to run a
project and all the focus goes into all
the fun parts which is
data cleaning crunching all the features
models and developing and of course
people want to see the results so you
need to start training it and you want
to get data online and you have to start
deploying it and then four months have
passed and you can't monitor it and
you're like well
i guess that's it let's move on to the
next project but i think here the
important part is that this last phase
and in general this entire flow whole
has to exist end to end in order for
your machine learning
uh system to be able to run in a
reliable way that you know it's safe and
secure
so if you don't have this all stacked
together and you don't start thinking in
a let's say in an integrated way in a
mvp way if you're thinking the kind of
agile world
then things will not work the way you
expect
because there is a
major issue and there have been other
talks the past days and a lot of them on
thursday there were from a novels and
then there were other talks from
about the great expectations library to
start tracking changes here i wanted to
quote one of my favorite artists
choo chain changes
nobody got the joke great
things will
inevitably change
and you cannot predict especially data
if you have set yourself some
expectations when you've developed your
model and train it
that certain things will work in a
certain way and now you got all this
nice performance and things are working
they will not a hundred percent
guaranteed um so maybe better get ready
for it
this meme is terrible i'll skip it
um
uh yeah all right let's start with some
practical stuff uh i mentioned that i
wanted to talk about them flow
what is it
um it's an open source platform uh that
works with python of course we are here
for pi data but actually the nice part
is that it works with a lot of other
different systems and the aim of this
project is to standardize
this set of tools and practices that go
around this envelops cycle that we
mentioned before
i think what's interesting about our
flow is getting a lot of traction
i've seen more than 10 talks only on pi
data in the past couple of
years
when i did these slides 5 million
downloads on pi pi 300 contributors it's
a pretty healthy infrastructure
it was originally developed by
databricks people but now it's open
source and sidenote i'm not affiliated
to databricks at all but i think it's
interesting if you're taking a tool in
your project to know how healthy the
system is if you want to start investing
time on this and hopefully
getting something that can you know
support your infrastructure for many
years to come
great k note from today about supporting
open source so i think this is just an
important topic to know
so what is it about um
you you can think of it as a system that
contains different components and they
call them i'm tracking projects models
and registry and each of these kind of
fulfills the different phases we're
tracking let's say which is the one that
i want to focus the most on is the one
about monitoring the system but then
there are things for wrapping the code
being able to deploy being able to save
models over time
and you can think of it as at least the
first part december flow tracking it's
kind of an extended
login database that understands machine
learning and i'm gonna
now show a little bit i hope the
image is not too small maybe it is
so the the the system at least for the
tracking part relies on two main
concepts experiments and runs now the
experiment let's say that is like the
main container of your project you could
call it like weather forecaster
one
um
and then each run would be for example a
new training
run for for this project let's say you
used linear regression with this in this
parameter on this data set on the
20th of june
and that is a run
now what you're seeing here is actually
the ui that emerflow provides on top of
the installation installation which is
by the way very simple it runs on
everything from windows yuck
to linux to docker kubernetes
um
and it can it can connect to a database
you can connect a file system and it
provides this ui that is also nice for a
human to look at and you can see here i
made a experiment you can see here now
called pi data 2022 and in this list
each of these
you can see them this time stamp lines
is
these are the ones and each one will
contain the informations that are
encapsulated in this one and now we'll
see how that works
and
some code
how do you actually make this happen
well it's very easy you install uh ammo
flow as you install any other package in
python and now it's there
and then we start setting these two
concepts i talked about so the first one
being an experiment super easy set
experiment give it a name and now it
exists in the database
um and then start and then run again
very simple methods and now practically
what happens all the code that is
brought within these two lines will be
part of this run so now we can start
using the functionalities of another
flow within this one to start tracking
interesting things
but what should i track
[Music]
that depends of course
and there is probably a whole
probably there is a whole field
that deals with this usually when i
start at least when we start a massive
you know everybody's time constraints we
start taking a look
things in a prioritized way so we start
thinking look okay
do i have the data quality that i expect
that's the input do the output on my
models perform in the same way that i
expect so i look at the performance of
my models over time in each of these
runs but then maybe also if i have more
time then we can start taking a look at
the code the configuration the
parameters on my system
uh maybe i also want to save the data
sets or sample of the data sets so that
then later on i can go back in time to
fifth of may and see what was the data
set at that time how did it look like so
you can add this also enamel flow run
and and i mentioned that there is a
whole field about it and again there
were some interesting talks about it
also
this conference the first days about
drifting so here the concept is
the data will change over time
and there are different metrics that are
already established
you can see all the math and the stats
online
um but the deal with the fact that the
input data will change and
and therefore the the outcome of your
model will change as well and the
ability to be able to track these things
over time so to track what is actually
called also stability which is the
change in this data drift the way it's
called
uh it's very important we'll not talk
too much about this because it's a whole
section by itself here we're going to
talk about how to actually make it
happen once you have decided what are
your metrics
so let's start taking a bit of look so
here now again i have my start and then
run and let's say that i have all my
code inside that is doing whatever
things you need to do data processing
cleaning training and whatnot and now i
want to start logging some metric and
it's actually pretty easy you just log a
metric and this is practically just
gonna add
one line of log in this one run
of this experiment and here for example
i'm taking examples of things that i
actually do i track really basic stuff
like what's the training set size what
the validations at size so perhaps i
want to see how they change over time
i want to start also maybe a little bit
of some basic quality checks for example
how many rows have dropped for example i
had some nulls that i had some rules for
and i decided to drop them
how many empty prediction labels i had
so how much corruption is in the data of
course again this depends
if i want to go a little bit more
dense into it and i look at things like
drifting like i mentioned before there
are also established metrics again we're
not looking at that and the example i
look at one feature what's the psi just
d distance
you can track literally whatever you
want of course here depends on how
eventually you use them but emerald flow
gives you the ability of tracking this
kind of metrics within a run that is
time stamped therefore it gives you an
idea of how things have moved over time
just interesting here metrics are just
key value pair in gamma flow world so i
can empire and i can just
consider them as a dictionary and save
them as log metrics and they save all
the metrics that i want which is pretty
convenient
just a side note of a thing that i like
uh
context managers mlflow actually
provides one right now i was showing
start and then run
easy thing but it just makes the code a
little nicer you can actually use a
context manager uh like the one that i'm
showing here the start run so now all
the code within this context manager is
within the run probably you seen other
context managers before like with open
file we're not really handy tool
um and it's also pretty smart um
because it handles crashes for example
which is a basic thing
so if something happens within this
context manager the enamel flow for
example an exception then flow
recognizes that the run did not end and
tags the
the run of this experiment with a
special status failed so you also know
that something happened when you're
looking into it
which is nice
you can also log tags
so far we talked about metrics or things
that you probably want to track over
time but it can also be interesting to
tag
destructive tags for your runs for
example
don't panic or
what kind of model you used what
what kind of parameters you have you
tried you can think of whatever kind of
descriptor you want to add to your run
you can
and you can also add if you have time
for it you can start login configuration
and data set we mentioned about it
before
we see other concepts the one of
artifact and the one or login the
dictionary so for the first one here log
artifact this is anything that is not
now for example a metric or a tag and
it's practically a file so in the
database world this would be a blob you
just practically have the possibility of
associating to your run any file and
here i have a really simple data set in
this dictionary with information about
planet earth and i'm making it into a
json and then i'm saving it this in the
file system associated to mlflow
and mlflow connects it to my run
and the same if i have a
configuration and in pattern it's often
again key value pair and it's a
dictionary that i have here then i can
log that with log dict and pass in the
configuration and again it gets saved
into the run
now we talked a lot about all the inputs
of the process but there is also the
output so what's the performance of the
model this is something that when we are
developing
um
we are working on a lot it's kind of the
main kpi of the whole system and you
probably
said what are your
your kpis in that sense accuracy f1
score position you know how to do it all
that part is very easy
right
um
but how do you track it well
it's practically just yet another metric
in our flow so now
on top of being able to
know what's your accuracy when you are
in development if you actually manage to
track it over time thanks to emerald
flow
runs
then now you are able to to know all
over each of your trainings uh
how the performance changes
but it's actually there is an
interesting parenthesis here
the yeah you can track these things
manually the way we've seen them but
emerald flow has a pretty cool tool
which is the possibility of interfacing
with the major machine learning
libraries think about scikit-learn
by spark ml tensorflow all that kind of
stuff
and the way it works is that it has an
auto logging feature
practically it
metrics that are exposed by for example
in psychic learn the fit the predict the
transform methods
they get automatically saved into the
run this takes a bit of the control away
from you but it gives you a head start
so you can get a hint of what is that
could be interesting to track
and the way it works is
again very simple here i have x and y
super simple data set i enabled the
emerald flow auto log
also notice i did not actually say that
what package i'm using it will recognize
it automatically
and then when i
instantiate within a run a linear
regression model coming from second
learn and then i fit it
automatically some basic metrics will be
saved you can see here in this one that
i'm showing
it say
for example the
main
square error
root mean square error the score it
added some tags about the description of
the model linear regression it also
automatically save the artifacts
connected to the model code so a lot of
things that uh are done automatically
for you so it also gives you a bit of a
start
if it's the first time that you're doing
this kind of things
now
we have tracked all our metrics over
time and perhaps things are going on
every day and we're tracking new metrics
uh but personally i've been in the
situation before both traditional
software and ml where i have a whole
database full of logs of information but
it's actually just sitting there and
nobody's looking at it besides you know
once in a while when a crash happens and
then i have to make a sql query
so how do you actually solve that
the first thing that we do when uh at
least that massive when we are
setting up this kind of project is that
we want to be able to have
continuous online monitoring on it
um so in most cases this means a
dashboard
and python has a lot of great options uh
so many of them panels streamlight voila
plotly dash and they're all great
but actually i'm lazy so i this is going
to be very anti-pattern uh i don't i
don't want to code it uh if if my
dashboards are really simple stuff um
i'm like
maybe i can just do it with drag and
drop
and actually grafana another open source
project that is currently really healthy
provides that kind of thing so again it
um a system that you can install
literally on anything and it's super
light
um
and it contains plugins for both
connections to all sorts of things and
plugins to display all other sort of
stuff
and how does it work here i have an
instance of grafana running on a docker
image
and practically here you're seeing
these are two
they call them panels uh
these are just time series of showing
the metrics that i've saved and you can
see here this one on the bottom maybe
the tags are a little small but
practically i'm showing
run over run each of these you know
points in the in the in the
plot
it's the training set and validation set
size
so this allows me to see over time very
clearly how things are going for these
two basic metrics you can do all kinds
of fancy stuff when you have more
advanced metrics
um
but again
being able to see things online over
time is not necessarily enough now yeah
data is not seen in in a database now
it's siri on a dashboard but am i going
to look at this dashboard every day 24
7. now maybe i want to set something
like alerts this can be basic
and very simple but i actually have not
always done it
but the cool thing is that grafana has
the concept of alert so again very easy
it's just an interface
and the concept here is that you can set
a threshold on the metrics that you're
displaying and if the value changes
over below you can set all kind of rules
then it can set up a notification
because again it has concept of
notification channels to
team slack email whatnot so that you can
also be notified on top of being able to
actually see
how things are going
uh and just to give an idea of how
simple things are to display these
values
the plugin was there of a time series
displayer and all i had to do was for
example in this case to connect to my
grafana
emerflow instance i'm connected to the
rest api that ml flow is providing
and you can see here i'm passing the url
of the runs and then i just need to find
the right metric so it's a json that i'm
receiving back so i can use a simple
jpath query to look into the metrics of
the run and then i just have to look for
the key for example in my case training
set size that i'm practically writing
here
and once i find that key then i can add
a column
which is the timestamp and the value of
of this specific metric these are things
that are coming from the json response
of the rest api of ml flow and then they
get visualized the way you just saw so
the connection is really easy because
these plugins are already in there
i'm not saying python is not easy
um
just a little bit of a
drop
the initial question that i asked the
beginning was do i need to monitor ml
machine learning
um i say
yes
my experience has been like a great
advantage to all the projects i've done
after you know the time in which i was
not doing it
it's as important as developing it
if you really want to start thinking and
you're working in the kind of scenario
where you really want to think of
productionalizing your models
then you definitely want to start
taking that kind of load off your
shoulder of always having to be like oh
things are not working and then i only
find out
when things are crashing then i have to
go back
on the other hand if you're asking
yourself this question and the answer is
no you're only doing research and you
want to stay in your notebook
don't even think about it right go ahead
this is a lot of overhead why would you
do it
but
be careful
are you really sure things are not going
to go in production
often they do
before you expect it because then all of
a sudden you're producing some really
interesting value and somebody's like
okay next week this is going and you
know like oh and now you are stuck
um on a system that is not monitored and
now you are the monetary and
probably would be there
um and the nice thing about
hopefully the things that i've shown is
that
things are actually pretty easy to set
up so you can have a monitoring system
on top of your run if you're working
with python uh pretty straightforwardly
and a bit on the other side of things uh
we know that often if you're if you're
working with product owners and project
managers they need maybe
there needs to be a little bit of
education also in the field so
all we've been thinking so far was the
development part
of a project
then this kind of
all these things around it they can get
a little bit forgotten
the problem is that in machine learning
things are going really fast and now
what a data scientist would do in your
days
maybe it's not enough maybe they want to
focus on the actual research and that's
why there are now different profiles
like machine learning engineers machine
learning operations engineers of course
data engineers
um so consider the things take time and
educate the people you're working with
on the fed there is a whole cycle
on top of the actual development if you
really want to produce value but you
also want to be safe
that whoever you're producing value to
is actually getting what they
wanted if you think this stuff is cool
which uh i hope you do you can get
started with emerald flow uh on the page
they explain how to install it on any
kind of system you are on
uh the same for grafana super simple
installation and you'll find the link in
the slides
uh you can also find for grafana some
really cool dashboard templates if you
want to get started real quick
uh if you want to contribute
they're both open source and very
healthy platforms so again links to
those and
and we got to the questions we have time
for it
so i hope you do have questions if you
want to contact me you first of all can
check the slides will be on github but i
guess they'll also be on slack somehow
if i send the link
you can try to write me on linden but
chances i'll answer are scars
but if you really want to contact me
then you can do it on playstation that's
my username or if you want to play the
division with me
which is a great game i'm not saying
just because i work with it then on
ubisoft connect i'm there with that
username uh hope to see you there and
thanks
[Applause]
thanks
um
questions
i'm going to pass the try and pass the
microrounds
thanks davide um we're also big fans of
using the um tracking feature in ml flow
however as you said these other three
pillars as you might want to call them
we rarely use them and we tend to use
rather custom deployments for model
serving and i was just wondering
what's your opinion on the the model
serving feature in ml flow have you ever
used it
would you recommend it for a particular
use case something like that
yeah
good question
um
i think that the
in my opinion while the
the monitoring part is nice because it
can kind of you can connect it to
anything you're on let's say you're
using some other stack
like you mentioned then it's kind of
easy to to get that one on top the other
ones are
more kind of a or thing so if you are
already on some other platform it's not
that obvious how do you use the emerald
flow serving
um
i don't have that much experience
because ourselves we also use another
platform but i think yeah it kind of
really depends on
what what what's the rest of your entire
stack if you're really able to use
the other parts especially the deploying
one for example the other ones the the
one about model registry that's also
easy to interface with something else
because it's kind of
in that one you're tracking the models
over time
uh but the deploying one i guess it's a
it's a bit trickier i would say
uh thanks for your talk david i had a
question about uh logging in the mlaps
lifecycle so do you have an open source
tool you recommend for that or are you
using uh something else
a
good question so vlogging you mean
so
all of your processes they produce uh
logs then you send them somewhere you
want to look at those logs what do you
use for that
and you're me and i guess here you mean
things that are not ml
flow related yeah not mfo or it could be
ml flow too you could redirect ml flow
to send the logs to that process
for example we're using
elasticsearch
but but we obviously paid them if
there's an open source tool i would
consider it question no i we actually
don't
use that kind of service we keep our
logs and then we have our
very custom ways of
getting information out of it so we
create practically our own pattern
scripts that look into the logs and
put them into dashboards and then we
save metadata and we do it but actually
we do it very custom
which is
kind of sad but i think it's because
there are not really a lot of options as
far as i know yeah that's that's the
experience we had too yeah
hi uh thanks for the talk
for someone starting out in in ml mlabs
which are some communities he could be
part of
all right so the
i mean i think this is a good one
there is a lot of things happening also
in the pi data meetups i see this topic
coming out more and more
there are specific conferences on on
envelopes as well i think one is called
emelop's world
which i have not managed to get to but i
see it's growing over time like compared
to three years ago it's getting bigger
and bigger and they keep having more and
more events so i think that's one of the
main ones
um
yeah
over here they're saying mlaps community
and it's actually just called mlaps
community
podcast nice to know
thanks for your talk um i was wondering
because uh i've been playing around a
bit with ml ml flosser in the past
around monitoring uh models during
training
uh are are you also using ml flow to
monitor the data drift you have at
prediction time if you are not like
continuously retraining your models
uh you still might want to have some
monitoring on how the input data and the
output of your models are
evolving over time do you have any yeah
have you been using mlf for that also we
are so i mean here i guess it goes back
to
what i at some point mentioned that if
you're tracking drifting which can be
like a complex
thing to track it really depends on your
domain what kind of things you want to
use but well we do use hammer flow for
that so we track it as other metrics and
of course this can be in conjunction
with other things like for example what
we talked about
great expectations which can set you
know some rules on how your drift is
changing
but this they're kind of fulfilled
different things so we use emerald flow
mostly for monitoring how things are
changing and then maybe you can have all
kind of other things that said
like stoppers or
tests on top of it but yeah we do
i think yeah this is going to be the
last one
thank you very much for the talk um how
would you when would you sort of
start thinking of hiring ml ops
engineers into the team um and so to
rather than having maybe this data
scientist
look at um what you just shown so the
best quality becomes maybe too much that
you really need to have full-time people
looking after these things
very good question
i'm actually the first of the mlaps
engineers at uh where i work
i think
it's hard to said was the tipping point
but
the the thing is
if you were starting to
let's say you are data scientist which
is kind of
like what in the past used to be the
major title but then you're starting to
spend your time with things like i need
to deal with infrastructure and now i
have all these models online and i need
to make sure that they're running and i
need to oh and log in oh and
the data has to be able to
you know be served to the model over
time and you're actually spending more
time with infrastructure let's say
more than 50 of your time is spent on
infrastructure than actually
developing working with the data itself
or working with the model and thinking
about business cases and being able to
research that's probably you want to
start thinking that maybe you need
somebody that supports you that
of course it also depends how many from
things you're running like how many
models
the more you have the more you will have
to spend on making sure that things are
running the same time so it's kind of
hard to say okay now you need it but
think about yourself and the work you're
doing
in your team or they
because you know data scientists and
machine learning engineers they work
want to work on different things so it's
also about self-fulfillment are you
actually doing the things you wanted to
do
yeah
thanks again davide for that talk
[Applause]